Q
WAS UP TOO.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS FOCUSSING ON
THE POSITIVE BUT THERE IS MORE
TO THE STORY.
PETER DOOCY LOOKS AT THE FACTS
AND FIGURES ONLY.
>> GAD EVANGELICAL.
-- GOOD EVENING.
THE JOBS NUMBER BEAT
EXPECTATIONS.
EXPERTS SAY IT'S JUST ONE SET OF
NUMBERS, THE PRESIDENT IS READY
TO CALL HIS ECONOMIC PLAN
A HISTORIC SUCCESS.
>> THE LAST TIME THE ECONOMY
GREW AT THIS RATE WAS 1984 AND
REAGAN SAID IT WAS MORNING IN
AMERICA.
>> 9.3 MILLION JOB OPENINGS
REMAIN.
A RECORD.
>> THERE IS NOBODY COMING IN FOR
A JOB.
WE ARE IN NEED FROM A BUS
PERSON, DISHWASHER.
PREP PEOPLE.
A COOK.
PIZZA GUY.
SNOW -- NO ONE COMES IN FOR
WORK.
>> THAT'S OKAY FOR NOW ACCORDING
TO THE LABOR SECRETARY.
>> THIS SHOWS THAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S ECONOMIC PLAN IS
WORKING.
>> A REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
WARNS THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
FALLING SHORT OF THE PROJECTIONS
FOR HIS JOB PLAN.
WORKERS ON THE SIDELINES AND
WAGES ARE GOING UP AND PRICES
ARE GOING UP FASTER.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THIS IS
POST-PANDEMIC PROGRESS.
>> PUT SIMPLY, OUR ECONOMY IS ON
THE MOVE.
WE HAVE COVID-19 ON THE RUN.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE'S VACCINATION
GOAL 70% OF ADULTS BY THIS
WEEKEND WILL BE MISSED BUT
CELEBRATIONS ARE OKAY.
>> BACK YARD BARBECUES.
>> THE COST OF BARBECUE IS DOWN
16 CENTS.
>> IF YOU DON'T LIKE HOT DOGS
YOU MAY NOT CARE IN THE
REDUCTION OF COST.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> I WILL STAY WHAT WE ARE MOST
FOCUSSED ON IS THE FACT WE
CREATED NOW MORE THAN 3 MILLION
JOBS SINCE THE PRESIDENT TOOK
OFFICE.
>> REGARDING THE ECONOMY, THE
WHITE HOUSE THINKS THEY ARE ON
A ROLL.
ON THE SUBJECT OF HOT DOGS
THERE, MY LINE OF QUESTIONING
WAS NOT A GRILLING.
I WAS JUST TRYING TO BE FRANK.
>> Shannon: YOU DID NOT.
MAYBE WE CAN POOL OUR 32 CENTS
TOGETHER AND YOU COULD HAVE
A COUPLE OF BITES OF HOT DOG.
PETER, WHAT ARE WE OTHER
THANKING ABOUT JOE BIDEN MEETING
WITH HUNTER BIDEN'S BUSINESS
PARTNERS BACK WHEN HE WAS
VICE-PRESIDENT?
>> WE HAVE A PICTURE OF A 2015
EMAIL.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE TIME STAMPS
ON THERE, THERE WAS PULLED OFF
THE LEFT BEHIND LAPTOP.
IT SHOWS HUNTER BIDEN TRYING TO
ARRANGE A COFFEE MEETING AT THE
NAVAL OBSERVE ATTORY WHERE THE
VICE-PRESIDENT LIVED.
IT SHOWS THE VICE-PRESIDENT AND
SEVERAL OTHER HUNTER BIDEN
ASSOCIATES.
THIS COULD CHALLENGE THE WHITE
HOUSE'S ASSERTION THAT SAID THE
SAME THING FOR TWO FULL YEARS.
THEY INSIST HE HAS NEVER SPOKEN
TO HIS SON ABOUT HIS OVERSEA